hello and welcome to this video playing
chess - with black alright so on do we
get I okay let's let's go for Petrov I
have a choice they at least and see what
white is coming up against the Petrov
well that is the most frequently seen
line nowadays I guess
4/6
yeah you have to that's it's always a
bit tricky there are so many different
moves orders and okay so 94 here
[Music]
I had to I had to remember this little
bit but this is okay I was robbed g8
okay me know why does a couple of ideas
now I can play c4 or h5 on various
various ideas of three okay
[Music]
yeah I think I'm just canceling him in
this particular position Bishop is seven
can be answered by Queen a forum so not
worried about it I always try to avoid
c5 in those some in those lines not that
it is super terrible but it's something
that I feel is a bit annoying sometimes
okay it's tough to avoid a six in the
long run
okay really g-form
not a move that I expected hmm I can't
go f5 a couple of I can't also do this
it's a little bit of a tidy up move this
this one but it's it's almost invariably
useful okay now you got play f5 you
would have g5 it's problem
probably going to happen I wonder if I
can play some D 5
in addition and D 5 lets him I see just
playing Queen Queen C 3 here mmhmm yeah
so I have 4 and he wants to play a 4
then it's slightly awkward it
immediately
okay the a Quincy six that was not great
hmm okay okay even the bishop on G 2 is
not exactly great so it's not that this
Quincy six movers losing immediately so
it was just silly
I'd like to clarify this present
situation damn it takes Luke a chain is
fine and he I got Bishop f5 but maybe
maybe even have six why not that tick
here he's putting I can putting quean a
quean III yeah I'm such an idiot
I'm such a [ __ ] yeah of course yeah
he's kind of telephoning his intentions
and I'm not seeing it that's just solely
stupid yeah now this is threatening and
this is threatened
very very idiotic he had I don't know it
was just I don't think this was so great
for what even though I played it badly
so quince is six and the engine actually
thinks d5 is right what I wanted to play
I just thought that after f4 I've got
I've got problems but I'm just better
here
it is silly I mean that was my idea
I wanted to play d5 and I'm just better
here according to the combo which is
quite clear that I'm better there if f4
isn't working which somehow was was my
concern I mean other than that this is
just a very stupid looking piece and I'm
nicely centralised hmm okay
I was that was bad I thought this is a
problem but it is not at all I mean this
is hanging got this stupid very stupid
plane yeah Queen d7 back is just idiotic
he played this I can't play d5 again
okay I played this g5 and now I'm
completely losing the plot didn't spot
this Queen e3 at all that's it's very
stupid okay I mean I haven't done I
wanted to play f6 and this is can
already be refuted by Queen e3 because
now is threatening this and in this
notice Queen 87 so yeah I mean I did I
totally made the wrong decisions here in
a row really d5 is fine and this if f6
is not working then this age 5 is stupid
I was
yeah Magister just very bad you know I
mean he missed that that immediate win
with Queen e3 and I don't really have
anything yeah I have those those bishops
are so stupid I mean I wanted to do this
and then next take but Queen e3 is just
the end of game and it's not good anyway
I mean the problem was I was really I
was really somehow believing that t5
doesn't work and that makes the whole
can of I mean it's only pointless to go
back and forth
bad okay anyway but it's what it is not
not a good game sometimes you just don't
really don't really get what's going on
when it's really really really when you
wanted to do this and it's extremely
logical anyway okay guys thanks for
watching